how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe due to covet 19
putting most of marvel studios recent
productions on hold
things have been pretty slow lately
however today we have some news about
shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings a plot leak from a
very legitimate source this apparently
is coming from an
extra from the set of shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings
and based off of everything that he's
heard he said it's going to be very
similar to doctor strange a
cocky hero an elder mentor supreme
magic user there's also going to be an
entity
kept at bay by a group of people just
like dormammu was kept at bay by the
masters of the mystic arts and the
ancient one
now this extra who was actually on set
for shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings
posted what he saw online but he also
posted his badge which had
a security sticker on it and it had
serial numbers on it meaning that marvel
studios could track him down if they
ever saw that so he has since
deleted it but again a very legitimate
source and we're going to break down
what he saw in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a cable versus deadpool funko pop
just subscribe
like this video and leave a comment down
below to enter so let's dive into this
plot leak it says that when the story
starts the mandarin and shang chi are
not enemies but
the mandarin acts as a mentor figure for
shang chi
but here's where things start to get
very interesting the dragon
fin fang fume is going to be introduced
in this movie
he goes on to say doctor strange
introduced the concept of magic to the
mcu
and showed us that there were sorcerers
all around the world that movie
established that three sanctums together
helped protect the earth
and it appears that concept of a magical
trinity will continue in chiang chi
and the legends of the ten rings where
there is a trio of wizards who are
tasked with keeping
fing fang foom dormant so it looks like
marvel studios is going to have its very
first
dragon in it and it looks like the film
is also going to include
several bits of magic and if we think
about this
this actually makes a lot of sense
because shang chi and the legend of the
10 ring so far
is scheduled for february 12th of 2021
and the next movie not disney plus show
but
movie is doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness coming in may 7th
of 2021 so the fact that shang chi
and the legend of the ten rings is going
to have sorcerers in it and
magic actually makes a lot of sense and
there are two things that shang chi and
the legend of the 10 rings and
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness actually have in common and that
is mordo mordo is confirmed to be
appearing in doctor strange too and
according to a plot leak that sounds
very similar to what we just saw which
we know is legitimate
mordo will be appearing in sheng chi and
the legend of the ten rings now as mcu
cosmic pointed out the dragon will get
free
somehow and perhaps this could be
mordo's doing
the last time that we saw mordo he said
there are too many sorcerers and since
this plot leak says that a trio of
wizards are tasked with keeping finn
fang fume dormant we know that something
happens with them or
to them because the dragon escapes and
perhaps what happens to them
is mordo mordo is going around getting
rid of sorcerers he's taking their
magical abilities from them and i'm sure
in some cases he's even killing them so
we have a trio of magical wizards who
fight
mordo and assumingly lose and this is
what sets the dragon free and that's a
whole
other problem for shang chi but this
does set up mordo to appear in the next
film doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness where he is continuing his quest
of getting rid of
sorcerers and it seems like he's going
to eye one of his very own apprentices
doctor strange but doctor strange is not
who he used to be and he's definitely
going to put up a big fight against
mordo and it will be nice to see the
classic doctor strange villain mordo
finally take the villain role in a movie
a lot of people thought that he was
actually going to become
ultimately the main villain in the first
doctor strange but he never did only in
the post-credits scene did we see that
he was really becoming a villain but now
we're going to see him face off against
doctor strange finally in multiverse of
madness and we're going to see him first
in shanghai and the legend of the 10
rings so let me know what you think
about this plot leak and let me know
what you think about a dragon coming to
the mcu
finn fang foom what would you like to
see as far as the story is concerned
with the dragon let me know what you
think in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof